is artificial intelligence a threat to
property investors is it going to change
the game for how we find property
deals the answer is absolutely
yes artificial intelligence is
completely changing the way that
certainly I find and Source my property
investment deals and I want to share
with you exactly how I'm using AI to
find my property deals and how I think
it's going to impact the future of
property investing I don't think it's
going to hind the property investors I
mean ultimately when you're investing
your money into a property I mean how's
AI going going to ruin that actually
it's going to AI is going to help it's
going to make things systemized it's
going to make things easier and it's
certainly easier now to find property
deals than it ever has
been so we can go to chat gbt and we can
say how to you find good property deals
in the you can Define your goals set up
budget okay that's all good let me ask
you another question we said can you
find me property deals I'm sorry but I
cannot find property deals for you as
I'm a text based AI all right cool so
chat gbt can't find as property deals
however there's a software that I use
called deal sourcer now I like this
software so much that I even own shares
in this now this software can actually
find deals so let's say you're looking
for a
HMO boom it's now found a list literally
scraped the whole of right move in the
internet and has found all these
different hmos this one in gloster's got
giving you a 1% return on investment so
you might think well that's pretty
rubbish but it's saying that it's
18% BMV which that's up the low market
value what this software is doing is
it's finding all the best deals and it's
bringing them together and I mean you
might not be interested in the return on
investment you might be looking to buy
stuff because you're just interested in
below market value so it's saying that
it's going to bring in
£2,900 a month gross yield of 7% you
can't get this information from right
move there's no other platform that will
colate all this information together in
the way that you can now do using AI so
450 Grand is that cheap or not well look
we can see the sold prices in the street
there's nothing that's selling for less
than 683 Grand we can see what that
looks like so let's see that's right in
the center as well that's sold for $ 950
to be fair it does look big this is the
how AI works now 83 Grand that's sold
for and then there's our house here that
was just found in seconds hm for 450 now
of course you don't just buy just
because AI said it's good you need to do
your own research as well but what this
is doing is just scraping the internet
collating all the information that's
currently available on the web and
putting it together in one place maybe
that will tickle your fancy or maybe
you'll say I don't want that kind of HMR
I want something like this I want a HMR
that's going to give me a better yield
so this is 135 Grand it looks like it's
already an existing HMR yes it is
currently being used as a HMR producing
an income of £2,000 a month currently
now let's say you could push that rent
up let's say you know you could get more
than that well look analyz deal so we
know we got five label rooms priced
offer 135 Grand the return invest 16%
which is pretty damn good now these are
all the figures that it's putting
automatically for us
but of course we can edit these let's
say for example that we said actually
we're not going to buy it for 135 grab
we're going to buy it cheaper because
we're currently in a buyer market so
we're going to buy it for 125 Grand well
that affects the return on investment to
18% it might be that the mortgage
payments 5.5% maybe you've not got good
credit and it's your first HMO property
and they're charging you 6% all right
well we can knock that up how does that
affect our return on investment well our
mortgage fee is now 400 6 a month knocks
it down to 17% but it might be you can
charge a little bit more for the rooms
it's saying that the rooms are renting
for 368 W that sounds a little low
that's what this AI technology has has
assessed the average room rents but
maybe you think actually I could Market
it better and I could maybe get
£425
24% okay that's the big difference there
okay so now the question is can we get
425 now we need to go and speak this of
hat management companies you never going
to be able to replace completely the
manual side of property investing you're
never going to be able to completely
throw your brain out the window and just
rely on AI but this is just a beautiful
way of finding good deals you might not
even want a hm own you might just want a
straightforward buy tette all right
let's say you want to buy tette
209,000 deals now let's say I'm only
interested in B tetes in Liverpool boom
21% Roi how long would it take to scroll
through right move find deals collect
all the information to be able to find a
deal that gives you 21% now instant it's
Madness click on this and then you can
go okay well is it actually does it need
a refer okay it looks like it's in
pretty okay condition maybe you might
want to spend a couple of grand on it so
let's say we buy it for 58 Grand and
then we spend two grand on the refi oh
he's already put two grand in the refi
here awesome okay rent is saying 650 R
is 18% at your fingertip
so this is going to be a huge change I
mean how is this going to affect deal
sources because there's a lot of people
that find deals like this and package
and sell them to investors for pretty
good money like three grand people still
going to pay three grand or would they
just pay for the software instead I I I
guess the answer is it depends on the
investor some people might do both this
costs I think it's around about £75 a
month so you know if you only want one
deal you might just St I'm just going to
pay a few Grands what this can't do is
it can't physically go out view the
property it can't get Builders quotes
yet but there's talk that it's actually
going to be able to from the pictures
work out the referb which is madness uh
let's say you want to find a leas option
agreement you want to find a house this
in negative equity now you can do this
on right move this is what I
historically have done I've gone to
right move typed in an area let's say
leads if I want to find a house in
negative equity on right move it's a
process the process looks like this I'm
going to start by looking for houses
that have probably been on the market a
long time oldest listed find the houses
that have been on the market forever
like this house it's on the market for
115 Grand it's been on the market for
over a year now and then I'm going to
see okay is this in negative equity if
you look at the property sale history I
can see that it last sold in 2005 for
72,000 and now it's on the market for
115 so it's not a negative equity to be
in negative equity you have to have
bought the house high now you're selling
cheaper than you paid for it which means
that your mortgage is likely to be more
than the value of the house if you keep
going looking and looking and looking
and looking and looking you might
eventually find a house that is in
negative equity or you can go to the
software just click the button negative
equity so these properties so let's take
uh this house it was bought for 105 now
it's on the market for 95 Grand negative
equity house very likely it is here's
another one the sold for 65 Grand but
now it's on for 55 grand just loads so
for finding lease option agreements this
is great you can search for Motivated
sellers means that they want cash quick
you can search for properties that have
got planning opportunities and there's
loads there's countless countless
countless properties these have all got
land opportunities for planning maybe I
don't want to do development maybe I
want to do just want to buy a straight
forward refurb opportunity 125 Grand
needs a refurb maybe this could be a buy
refurbish find that's opportunity so I
think AI is massively going to change
the entire process from a deal finding
perspective if you're a deal sorcer he
also going to be really good for you
because you might feel threatened right
now as a deal sorcer go oh oh AI is
taking over our business but here's the
thing most people don't even know this
software exists and if they did know it
existed they might not necessarily be
ready to subscribe and stop paying the
subscription fee for it or they might
not trust AI as a deal sourcer this is
like gold dust what you can do now is
you can just find all of these beautiful
deals but then go and view them put the
offers forward put your own little PDF
together which this will actually do for
you ironically cuz look if you find a
property analyze the deal you can then
download the spreadsheet and just
download on spreadsheet Madness as a
deal sourer of course you know no
Investor's going to give you money for a
deal unless you've actually been out
you've seen it you've negotiated it but
this is going to be a huge tool so if
you're a deal sourcer at the moment and
you're selling you know one or two deals
a month maybe you could utilize this
this artificial intelligence start
selling a deal or two a week and triple
your or or quadruple your profits
because I bought shares in this company
I've managed to get the director of this
AI software to agree to do a free trial
period so as I say disclaimer is I am a
shareholder but if you want to use this
software you can do completely for free
for 7even days so I'm going to leave a
link in the description which is Samual
leads.com
SLV virtual and you can use it check it
out find a load of deals cancel it if
you want or don't cancel it pay for it
that's what I'd suggest but definitely
in 2023 as we enter into 2024 I would
say lean into AI let it help you let it
become your best friend because it isn't
going
away